last night russia decided to invade
ukraine obviously this is a very serious
situation i think it's important to
understand the economics behind these
types of decisions the people in ukraine
many of them may lose their lives and
obviously most of them have no appetite
for violent conflict i hope all of them
are safe also on the russian citizen
side many of those citizens also have no
appetite for violent conflict as well
simply what we have are governments
engaging in war in invasions if we begin
to understand what some of the economics
behind this invasion end up being what
we first have to understand is that
russia has over 600 billion dollars in
their central bank reserves of foreign
currencies in gold so not u.s dollars or
not other types of assets 600 plus
billion dollars of foreign currencies
and gold
on top of that russia is one of the
largest producers of oil and natural gas
in the world russia is responsible for
about 17
of all natural gas produced in the world
and about 12 percent of all oil
as you can see here russia has a ton of
natural gas lines that also run through
ukraine as well
there's a lot of geopolitical complexity
that goes on in these situations but
ultimately what we have seen over the
last two years is that the price of oil
has continued to rise over time
in the united states and abroad everyday
citizens are paying more for gasoline at
the pump and for various other uses of
that energy production but now all of a
sudden russia who's the third largest
oil producer in the world as the price
of oil rises which is now trading at
over a hundred dollars per barrel the
international community has to keep
buying oil from russia that means that
at the same moment that they're invading
ukraine we're also having the
international community united states
and their allies continuing to purchase
higher priced oil which is putting more
money into the coffers of russia if we
go ahead and we look at the oil itself
what you can see here is the united
states is the number one oil producer in
the world russia being number three but
the reason why this is important is
because even though the united states is
the largest producer they also happen to
be the largest consumer as well the
united states is actually a net importer
meaning that we need and are reliant on
other countries producing oil in order
for us to have enough to satisfy our
consumption russia on the other hand is
a net exporter of that oil and so
they're benefiting drastically from the
rise in oil prices if we continue to
look here you can see that russia's
crude oil ends up going to europe and
asia two places that are close
geographically to their jurisdiction if
we then go ahead and look at the russian
trade surplus what we can see is that
they continue to surge even though there
are rising tensions and now an actual
invasion on top of oil production and
the money that's being made with higher
oil prices
russia also has that 600 plus billion
dollars of foreign currencies in gold
gold is up about 5
over the last 30 days or so and so
ultimately not only is russia making
more revenue from the higher price of
oil but they also are watching their
balance sheet grow in value as well
because that gold is going up in price
war is a really really ugly thing people
die people are displaced and ultimately
it ends up moving us further and further
away from a place of harmony globally
but what is important to understand is
that there is 3d chess going on here in
some way
russia has figured out that they can
apply pressure that they can call the
bluff of the united states and nato and
they can make money while they do it
this obviously didn't happen overnight
and so what we've seen over the last few
years is that russia their central bank
and their government they're playing a
long game and ultimately now the
question is going to be how will the
united states and nato respond how
severe will the economic sanctions be
what is the appetite for violent war in
response i don't have those answers i'm
not an expert on geopolitics but when
you follow the money
it's absolutely surreal to watch what's
playing out here